what's the meanest thing your child has
said to you kim kardashian west gets
real about mom life in a new ellen tube
video and reveals the meanest thing her
eight-year-old daughter north west has
said to her every time i get into some
kind of disagreement with my daughter
north she thinks this is a dig to me and
she'll say your house is so ugly it's
all white who lives like this and
because moms are human too kim admits
that jab does hit her where it hurts she
just thinks it like gets to me and it is
kind of me because i like my house the
40 year old mom of four also revealed a
trait of hers that her mini knees have
but wishes they didn't my love for
makeup because they're too young i don't
know but then i kind of like it because
they're super creative and they do like
fun costume looks kim shared one of
those fun looks created by north to
instagram earlier this year
captioning it quote my creative baby
north was testing out some makeup looks
she thinks i should do for some shoots
she was also testing out special effects
makeup tricks and used tissue on her
cheek and covered it in foundation to
look like a scar i love seeing the look
she creates yeah she really isn't a
beauty back to those mom confessions
when it comes to her biggest parenting
fail kim revealed that she gives in too
easily sometimes and bribes i'm guilty
of a good bribe and as for her number
one piece of advice to people who want
kids maybe it'll calm you everyone's
winging it just wing it you'll figure it
out well one thing kim didn't win was
her snl hosting debut i'm just so much
more than that reference photo my sister
showed their plastic surgeons before her
big night a source told et that the busy
mom quote wants to do the best job
possible and wow everyone and make them
laugh and that she did i know you little
girls ain't laughing at me for your
information i wasn't asleep i was
resting my eyes why are you worried
about me but now i'm wide awake and
although kim was off mom duty at the
time she did have close friends and
family like her mom chris and sister
chloe by her side well i'm suing kendall
because she has absolutely no drama
she won't cause any drama and it's
damaging our brand
i'm a jenner not a kardashian
and that's something you need to work on
honey
a source tells et that even her
estranged husband kanye west was in the
audience during her opening monologue
and later went backstage that was like
such a fun time in 2017 kim opened up to
e.t about what she hopes her kids take
away from watching her juggle motherhood
and her career i hope that they
just find their own motivation and no
matter what that is no matter what they
want to do in life i hope that they work
really hard i think they have good exam
i learned from seeing both of my parents
work really hard and i think our kids
will see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path they think
to not
pressure but to definitely have our our
rules
um
is the best that you can do
[Music]